Quinton
hello hello
so uh
I was the guy that was on here a couple
months ago my fiance had passed away my
LTR
and now I haven't I had a new girlfriend
she's got pregnant
on accident
okay well now we're broken those don't
usually happen by accident yeah that's
true you know how the birds and the bees
work right so yeah so what's the ask
here
um so should I like just try to stay
cordial with her she's she's chill she
never wants to take me for child support
right now anyway but
but uh
right now yeah it's always a right now
thing like you said I always say they
have the right to change their mind at
any moment I'll do but uh 29 she's only
21.
okay and so you guys broke up after you
found out she got pregnant she I think
she got super scared and
like she'd never she hasn't even moved
out of her house or anything and is she
having the baby
yeah she doesn't believe in abortion
okay well you're gonna be a father yeah
but I just started investing into some
rental properties
and uh are those uh
are they able to come after me in child
support for my rental properties because
of the depreciation and
child support's based on your income so
if it's earned income
it's tax it's look it varies from state
to state and throughout Canada is pretty
much the same like where do you live uh
Pennsylvania
yeah I don't know that's a very
Democratic State you can talk to
um Jonathan Noble he's in Pennsylvania
he's licensed to practice law there so
um he's been in a few of my videos you
can find him on Twitter uh John Noble
Esquire I think is his handle if I'm not
mistaken
um if you want to pay for his time to
get some legal advice that's where I
would go to get legal advice I mean okay
you're kind of asking vague questions
like okay well
um oh yeah I just passed away and now I
knocked up this girl and she's not with
me so it's like yeah what do you want me
to say dude you know like I don't have a
time machine to put you back into it and
throw around him on it so it's like you
know what are you gonna do
well I'm just going to be there for my
child I don't know it's just like I feel
like I dove into the red pill a little
bit and then I like pulled back
and I feel like I need to like stake
what would you say like current like
making myself
watch content so that way I don't fall
back into
what would you say well well what
content are you watching
I pretty much just watch yours I've been
reading a lot of books like I got your
audiobook I got rollo's audiobook
I just got the 48 Laws of Power
uh Aaron clary's book
yeah
so like I go but I got them all too late
okay like I just started listening to
all of them so I would I would recommend
um look if
if you're gonna be a father I mean deal
with that when you have to cross that
obviously because you know there's
you know like nothing's for certain I
mean you gotta wait for the chicks to
hatch sort of thing so
um
kids need a father you've got a chick
that you're in a relationship with for a
period of time
um you're just adding another one to the
[ __ ] rosters of single mommies now
right I mean you made her a single Mommy
so what are you gonna do I mean you know
you got to figure that out but if you
want to if if you want to be involved in
the kid's life and that's and that's
important to you then do it I mean
there's guys that would just run too
they just [ __ ] it I'm gonna go to the
Philippines right so yes there's guys
from every every angle they can handle
it from but as far as money goes in
child support you'll be okay uh like
child support's not that much yeah I
also don't get taxed very much I do
travel nursing so a lot of my money
comes from untaxable wages so
Ernesto just uh made a good point uh get
a DNA test yeah I was already going to
get a paternity test yeah if she wants
to claim that you're the father and she
wants to come at you for money okay
let's get a test too just to make sure
that I am the father in fact
yep I was already gonna do that I was
going to do it without her knowing so
that way it doesn't throw like a wrench
into things
I don't know if you can do that you're
gonna have to ask a lawyer really
I thought you can do like uh you can
just go get a DNA test maybe not I'll
have to look at that there's there's
like the female first primary social or
has has gotten so involved in parenting
and family and births I know in parts of
the world it's prohibited right like I
believe in France if I'm not mistaken
you can't even do a paternity test it's
illegal you know I'll have to do it and
it's going to differ from from state to
state so uh again I mean
is she consents then that's good if
she's not going to consent then you
might want to talk to a lawyer but I
would definitely get a paternity test
otherwise you could be on the hook for
raising some other dudes kid yeah that
was that's like one of the the scariest
things in life it's like oh I'm raising
this kid but it's not mine well it
happens somewhere between 10 to 30
percent of the time yeah because
paternity fraud relies on Deception
you're never going to get honesty from
the mother because she's doing what's
best for herself with the kid because I
mean yeah politicism and if she points
the finger oh that guy's got money he's
got real estate I'm gonna say he's a
father it happens it happens 10 to 30
percent of the time so
um it's advisable to get a paternity
test unless you've got 100 certainty
which is almost impossible to have
yep okay all right man thank you hey
guys I really hope that you enjoyed that
short clip if you did consider
supporting the creation of content by
checking out my supplement line pinned
in the top comment below of this video
in the comments there's a link to the
unpluggedalpha.com forward slash shop
when you click through you'll be able to
land over here and the entire lineup is
broken down by category that it performs
best in estrogen metabolism fat burning
your foundational Essentials for health
immune Health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code Alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the Subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching I
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out